Trascrizione: Cristina Marras
Revisore: Martina Margoni
Buongiorno a tutti.
Eccomi qua, mi occupo
di qualcosa che non esiste,
l'ingegneria della consapevolezza.
Sono ingegnere, mi occupo appunto
di un'ingegneria che non esiste,
questo mi sembra un validissimo motivo per parlarne con qui con voi a TED.
L'ingegneria della consapevolezza
è un argomento, una disciplina
anzi, diciamo che è una multidiscplina
che sta all'incrocio preciso, perfetto, oserei dire armonico,
tra la medicina, le nuove tecnologie e il design.
Questi, diciamo così, sono gli strumenti che noi abbiamo per rendere migliore la qualità della nostra vita
intesa in un senso più ampio del termine, e l'obiettivo dell'ingegneria della consapevolezza
è di disegnare, creare e rilasciare nell'ambiente reale
dei sistemi, o meglio degli ecosistemi, che favoriscano l'esercizio del libero arbitrio,
attraverso la consapevolezza individuale,
per fare in modo che i comportamenti individuali e collettivi
possano volgere verso dimensioni di maggiore salute individuale e collettiva,
di maggiore sostenibilità dal punto di vista ambientale
e anche di maggiore responsabilità di tipo sociale.
Il nostro laboratorio è... non è piccolo, è molto grande,
è quello che vedete:
è un'intera microcittà dove 25 mila persone al giorno
vengono per moltissimi motivi.
Ovviamente il motivo principale è avere dei servizi di cura,
e questo che vedete è esattamente, diciamo così,
il laboratorio, una città laboratorio
con 25 mila persone al giorno,
che è cresciuta attorno a un grande ospedale,
con un grande centro di ricerca,
ma con anche negozi, alberghi, metropolitana
e, ovviamente, si mangia, c'è il catering, ci sono le mense
tutto questo ecosistema,
è il laboratorio di questa ingegneria della consapevolezza.
Ci sono tre linee di ricerca
che il mio gruppo tiene...
sotto controllo e sviluppa quindi, progetti di ricerca.
Uno è l'ospedale del futuro.
Il secondo è la vita del futuro, in quest'ottica di favorire stili di vita molto più sostenibili
dal punto di vista individuale e collettivo.
Il terzo è la città del futuro, perchè noi non possiamo
permetterci di avere dei sistemi per la persona
che non siano coerenti con l'ecosistema
nel quale la persona vive.
Quindi queste tre linee di ricerca non possono essere distinte,
devono essere per forza organiche l'una con l'altra,
e sono l'oggetto della nostra attività di ricerca.
Siamo parte del network europeo del Living Lab,
e ci occupiamo appunto di questi tre temi in questo contesto,
e la parola salute a cui faccio riferimento,
non è una mia definizione personale,
una mia aspirazione, un mio punto di vista,
la nostra missione è quella di realizzare la visione
dell'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità, ovvero della salute,
che quando è stata fondata ha definito la salute non come semplicemente
l'assenza di una malattia, o la cura di una malattia,
ma lo stato di benessere fisico,
psichico e sociale.
Questa è la dimensione olistica della salute.
Ora, come facciamo noi,
singoli individui,
all'interno del mondo che conosciamo, al supermarket,
nella vita quotidiana,
in cucina, correndo a portare i figli a scuola,
i bambini stessi a scuola, o nel pomeriggio, quando studiano,
tutti noi, noi stessi sul luogo di lavoro,
come facciamo noi a organizzarci al meglio,
per garantire che il nostro libero arbitrio,
che la nostra consapevolezza sia massimizzata?
Ci arrangiamo.
Abbiamo tanti servizi, dobbiamo passare come delle api
da un servizio all'altro.
Ma ogni volta che ci muoviamo all'interno di questo servizio
siamo nessuno che si muove all'interno o meglio, uno
di una massa che si muove all'interno di un servizio che è stato disegnato
non per me, ma per centinaia di miglia di persone,
sostanzialmente in maniera tutta uguale.
Quindi il primo dei problemi è
come faccio io, individuo
ad avere il controllo di quello che voglio,
di quello che mi serve,
di quello che mi piace,
mentre mi muovo all'interno di un ecosistema
che non mi riconosce se non per un pagamento,
piuttosto che non per qualche funzione molto specifica?
Per fare questo noi abbiamo sviluppato un concetto
che appunto è la creazione di un database,
dove la dimensione fisica della persona, ovvero,
se volete, la cartella clinica,
il mio colesterolo, le mie caratteristiche fisiche,
vengono unite alle mie preferenze culturali, personali,
e questo insieme di condizioni, insieme alla misura
e al monitoraggio dei miei comportamenti -
nell'ottica di essere consapevole di avere un feedback su quali sono le mie attività,
diciamo così, quotidiane,
crea un unico database, sostanzialmente,
in cui queste tre dimensioni diventano un unico strumento
che è - e qua lo voglio specificare molto bene -
che è nelle mani della persona,
non è nelle mani delle aziende
o dei servizi che offrono, i propri prodotti,
i propri servizi alla persona.
È nelle mani della persona
e questa persona è in grado quindi
di poter ribaltare il paradigma
per cui mi offrono qualcosa
e io devo scegliere fra tante offerte,
non avendo il tempo di comprendere qual è l'impatto
che quella scelta
avrà sulla mia vita personale, sull'ambiente, sulla società.
Questo è il nostro modello di sviluppo
dell'Ingegneria della Consapevolezza,
che come vedete si svolge secondo tre assi:
uno è la funzione il mio sistema deve fare qualcosa,
mi deve servire, se no non è sufficiente.
Ovviamente deve generare un'emozione alla persona,
quello che tecnicamente si chiama
una user experience che però deve essere personalizzata:
la voglio per me, su misura,
come se fosse un abito fatto sulle mie preferenze,
sui miei bisogni.
Ovviamente la dimensione della relazione:
non voglio essere isolato,
voglio essere messo in relazione con l'ambiente e con gli altri.
Sviluppare questo tipo di sistemi
trasforma un sistema frammentato, in cui la persona
si arrabatta con il poco tempo che ha a disposizione
a muoversi tra mille condizioni,
ad un sistema coerente
in cui la persona ha il controllo della situazione
e può invece che essere oggetto di,
come dire, riversamento di informazioni non personalizzate,
quando non addirittura spamming,
può fare viceversa, può controllare le informazioni
ed estrarre quelle che sono significative.
In pratica, dal punto di vista - come si dice
tecnicamente - architetturale, è un database che interroga,
che ha un profilo, e interroga tutti gli altri database
dei servizi ed estrae le informazioni
che sono contestualmente e personalmente
rilevanti per quella persona, ed è nel controllo della persona.
Ovviamente la privacy
è il paradigma fondamentale
per poter esercitare questa capacità
e questo diritto,
e sostanzialmente quello che vedete è...
il modello di riferimento di questo sistema
che interagisce, ovviamente attraverso i telefoni cellulari
e attraverso canali di interazione sicura,
e attraverso tutta una quantità di altri terminali o
di interazioni machine to machine cioè tra macchine,
senza che io sia scocciato da cose
a cui non sono particolarmente interessato,
in modo che tutto intorno a me sia fatto
più su misura possibile per me e soprattutto
mi renda consapevole delle cose che mi riguardano.
Ora la consapevolezza noi la vediamo come un diritto,
oserei dire un diritto costituzionale.
L'informazione non è sufficiente,
l'informazione è uno strumento,
la conoscenza non è sufficiente,
la conoscenza è uno strumento.
A noi serve avere l'obiettivo in mano.
L'obiettivo per esercitare il libero arbitrio
è essere consapevoli.
Quindi, come ogni diritto,
ho anche il diritto, diciamo così,
a non avere consapevolezza.
Infatti mi basta spegnere, schiacciare un bottone
e posso vivere consapevolmente
la mia vita inconsapevole
perché questo fa parte dell'esercizio del nostro libero arbitrio.
Ovviamente adesso noi spegniamo il sistema,
non siamo più consapevoli,
viviamo la vita che ci permette...
[di viverla] come la vogliamo vivere,
siamo consapevoli delle nostre informazioni,
delle nostre conoscenze.
Adesso, giusto per intrattenere gli ultimi cinque minuti con voi,
vi voglio far vedere, noi riaccendiamo questo sistema istantaneamente,
vediamo qualche piccolo estratto,
video fotografico dei progetti di ricerca internazionali
che noi facciamo sull'argomento.
Quindi adesso partiamo da un piccolo esempio molto, molto medicale,
però d'mpatto sulla vita quotidiana delle persone: i farmaci.
Ricordarsi quando prendere i farmaci,
ho preso il farmaco, non l'ho preso nella sequenza giusta,
ho preso questo farmaco, posso prenderlo insieme a quest'altro,
ho preso questo farmaco, posso mangiare questa cosa
una quantità di informazioni che vanno sotto il nome di
aderenza alla terapia che, in realtà,
sono un grave problema, soprattutto in una
popolazione che tende ad invecchiare,
quindi la necessità di prendere farmaci diventa molto alta
e l'avere promemoria e informazioni certificate profilate e personalizzate
sull'argomanto è un elemento sostanziale
per garantire la capacità di aderire spontaneamente -
senza costrizione, senza patema d'animo
e senza anche errori gravi sulla persona -
ad una terapia farmacologia.
Qua avete visto un armadietto informatizzato
che interagisce con la persona,
la riconosce ed estrae questo tipo di informazioni
chiaramente dando dei segnali giallo, rosso, verde
per far capire alla persona
qual è l'impatto sulla scala dei valori che essa stessa
ha dichiarato all'interno del proprio profilo.
Qua vediamo gli altri tre...
le altre tre linee di ricerca
su cui noi siamo attivi.
Sostanzialmente l'educazione,
l'attività fisica e la nutrizione.
Vediamo alcuni esempi di interazione al supermarket,
tutte attività che in progetti di ricerca pilota
abbiamo eseguito all'interno della città
che vi ho prima dimostrato.
Con queste informazioni che vengono personalizzate
nel momento dell'acquisto.
Questo è un progetto di vending machine che
son trasformate in giganteschi
iPad, quindi non interagisco col telefonino,
interagisco come con un gigantesco iPad,
ed ho questi servizi personalizzati.
Qua sono... queste vending machine sono da più di un anno
attive nella zona commerciale del San Raffaele.
Qua vedete alcuni elementi
di funzione,
non voglio dettagliare questa attività,
voglio solo farvi vedere le cose che si muovono
per dare il senso ingegneristico di queste cose.
E' una teoria che diventa pratica
ed è una pratica che entra nella vita quotidiana
attraverso un laboratorio che è una città intelligente,
su scala ridotta, ma che interagisce con le persone nella quotidianità.
Ovviamente questo paradigma noi lo stiamo reimpostando,
visto che ha funzionato oserei dire, molto bene,
lo stiamo reimpostando per il luogo di lavoro,
per il retail del futuro, come si dice,
e soprattutto, soprattutto per le scuole
per le scuole, dopo vedete alcuni argomenti
che riguardano
il ruolo del bambino e delle scuole nella società.
Abbiamo fatto tutta una linea di progetto,
un'intera piattaforma, questa in particolare
si chiama - è la più importante che abbiamo -
si chiama feed for good, per favorire
un approccio educativo e di miglioramento
degli skill, nel cucinare, nel vivere la vita quotidiana
perchè questi sono aspetti motivanti
anche per scegliere stili di vita alimentari più salutari.
Abbiamo fatto la stessa cosa
per promuovere l'attività fisica.
Qua vedete molte app, piuttosto che non sensori,
che sono integrati in questo gigantesco sistema
di appropriazione dei propri dati dell'individuo
in modo da poterli utilizzare in maniera coerente.
Qua ci sono alcune fotografie del sistema funzionante.
Adesso spendo gli ultimi tre minuti che mi rimangono
per parlare dei bambini
che sono sostanzialmente i più grandi innovatori
che la società ha a disposizione.
Qua vedete molti videogiochi, sistemi di edutainment [educare col divertimento]
che noi ne abbiamo realizzato.
Ve ne faccio vedere alcuni in movimento.
Questo è un robot che aiuta gli insegnanti a scuola,
i medici in ospedale,
a gestire l'interazione col bambino
favorendo la dimensione educativa
nei confronti del bambino. Perchè potete immaginarvi
un insegnante, un medico che sono associati,
hanno come aiutante un attore così fantastico
come un piccolo robotino umanoide
che interagisce contestualmente,
e aiuta nella gestione dell'interazione col bambino,
vedete assolutamente,
potete immaginare chiaramente quanto i bambini
sono felici di imparare
all'interno di un ecosistema che è, ripeto,
personalizzato bambino su bambino.
Qua vedete alcuni esempi.
L'altro esempio è l'ambiente
che ruota attorno a questo robotino,
quello che noi chiamiamo la piattaforma scuola-giochi,
che è un sistema di lezioni interattive
con video giochi, socialità, raccolta di figurine integrate,
che in realtà sono compiti in classe.
Questi sono compiti in classe di cui voi vedete
il look and feel in questo momento.
E, ovviamente, adesso stiamo lavorando sull'attività fisica
per promuovere questa ulteriore dimensione
della vita quotidiana.
Vi ringrazio.
[Applauso]